there's a really interesting segment
from the weekend where a conservative
superhero ben shapiro was interviewed by
the BBC's Andrew Neil and ben shapiro
cut the interview short over what he
perceived to be the liberal bias of the
interviewer and he's now ended up
apologizing it and the most interesting
thing about all of this to me is that it
happened because ben shapiro abandoned
some of his supposedly most important
principles he's against identity
politics and he's four facts over
feelings and in short ben shapiro made a
call the wrong call about the identity
of the interviewer as a lefty which
andrew Neil is not and that identity
based decision that ben shapiro made was
based not on the facts but on ben
Shapiro's feelings about the interviewer
which is the opposite of ben's facts
over feelings mantra so let's get right
to it
this is andrew Neal who was in the
conservative club in college he worked
for the British Conservative Party he
was a correspondent for the conservative
publication The Economist and the point
is there is no leftist progressive
streak to Andrew Neil by any means and
Andrew Neil asks ben shapiro to defend
things that ben has said he asked simple
questions and ben can't handle it he was
triggered that he wasn't given a safe
space on BBC so he implodes ends the
interview early let's look at one clip
first where ben's feelings sort of get
the best of him and he attacks the
journalist rather than talking about
ideas some of the ideas that are popular
in your side of politics would seem to
take us back to the dark ages georgia
knew abortion laws which you are much in
favor of that
a woman who miscarries could get 30
years a georgian woman who travels to
another state for an abortion procedure
could get 10 years these are extreme
hard policies well okay a couple of
things one i'm not sure i mean frankly i
don't know whether you're sitting are
you an objective journalist are you an
opinion journalist I'm a journalist to
ask questions okay so you're a
supposedly objective journalist calling
policies with which you disagree
barbaric
one side of the political aisle knows
ideas so I just want to point out that I
know what you should at least be honest
in your own bias this is your parenting
are you are you're nothing in America is
not so polarized in one program you only
have the left and another one you just
have the right my job is to question
those who have strong views and put an
alternative to them would you suggest
that a late-term abortion is brutal I'm
not taking a rehabilitation - Ally -
more question and eventually Ben has
just had enough and can't handle it when
his identity argument implodes he does
add homonyms that the interviewer is
less than Ben because Ben hasn't even
heard of the interviewer that's a form
of personal attack and ad hominem and it
really gets ugly and more importantly
very very stupid why is it that a bill
banning abortions after a woman has been
pregnant for six weeks is not a return
to the dark ages what's your answer my
answer is something called science human
life exists at conception it ought to be
protected now back to my question to you
you purport to be an objective
journalist BBC purports to be an
objective down the middle network it
obviously is not it never has been and
you as a journalist are proceeding to
call one side of the political aisle
ignorant barbaric and sending us back to
the dark ages why don't you just say
that you're on the left is so hard for
you I can't just be honest this is it's
a serious question
mr. Shapiro if you only knew how
ridiculous that statement is you
wouldn't have said it I just leave you a
question and I asked you a question you
failed to answer a single one of mine
frankly I find this whole thing a waste
of time if you want to read the book and
critique the book why don't you read and
critique the book if you want to read if
you want to critique me you can think
whatever you want to me I don't give a
damn what you think of music I've never
heard of you you and I've never heard of
you until I brief myself of this but
that's not the issue you have it's an
interesting book but my point is your
book claims it from time to time your
book is called you I've done so several
times and I'm about to do so again if
you would let me just finish the
question you bet returning on
judeo-christian values this is
where are the values it's turning its
back on I you know I'm not inclined to
continue an interview with a person is
badly motivated as you as an interviewer
so I think we're done here I appreciate
your time all right well we thank you
for your time and for showing that anger
is not part of American political
discourse now mr. Shapiro will say
goodbye so this didn't go well Shapiro
ended up apologizing to Andrew Neal and
saying that he misinterpreted Neil's
antagonism as political leftism
and this is a case study in why identity
arguments and letting your feelings
override the facts are bad ideas which
normally ben shapiro tells us is what we
should be paying attention to right
there's an identity argument here Ben
ended the interview over the perceived
political identity of the interviewer
not the ideas not the questions or the
issues being brought up it's sort of
identity politics in Reverse ben shapiro
is against the type of identity politics
that says my opinion is more valid or
particularly valid because of my
identity and i agree that when the
identity is used as a cudgel in that way
it's very bad and i've spoken out
against it but in this case Ben's taking
the identity politics position of Andrew
Neil's opinion is invalid because I
perceive him to be a liberal of course
Neil is not a liberal he also wasn't
taking a position he was just
interviewing Ben about things that he
has said it was a decision that been
made based on his feelings and not on
the facts Ben felt that hard questions
about his positions were leftist they
weren't Andrew Neil has a life of
conservative political credentials Ben's
being interviewed about the opinions
that he has espoused and writes about in
his book so why does he start asking the
interviewer for his opinions the
interviewer is interviewing been asking
what has been believed and it is a very
beta move when you start telling the
interviewer to give you their opinion
when you're unable to defend the things
that you've said during your life but
then the real Miss point here is that
Ben tweeted something about being
destroyed by Andrew Neil or something
like that
this wasn't a debate right Neil was
playing the role of a journalist Neil is
personally conservative but he
identified
problematic statements that ben shapiro
has made and he asked questions about
them and been lost what was not actually
a debate because he just jumped in
assumed that the interviewer had
left-wing bias and then uh yeah I guess
Ben's used to getting the kid gloves
safeSpace treatment by American
conservative media outlets and what Neal
did was yes he quote destroyed then but
he destroyed him without really do
anything he just asked him to to defend
his claims and then was unable to his
feelings overrode the facts identity
ended up with Ben saying I'm out of here
and it is an extraordinarily fascinating
case study in how in many of these cases
the principles that these right-wingers
claim to espouse and hold up as the most
important thing grow out the window to
get thrown out the window no identity
politics well you ended the interview
over the perceived identity of the
interviewer feelings don't care about
the facts well it seems don't care about
the feelings rather in this particular
case been ignoring the facts and letting
his feelings dictate how he behaved
during that interview which was by the
way extraordinarily embarrassing very
funny I wish they would just live up to
the principles that they espouse that's
all I'm asking for let us know your
thoughts about this will be posting
about it on our Instagram page at david
pakman show quick break back after this